we're asked to write this right here in
Word form and I'm not saying it out loud
because that would give the answer away
we have six 3.15 that we want to write
in Word form well the stuff to the left
of the decimal point is pretty
straightforward let me actually color
code it so we have six three and then we
have a let me do it all in different
colors six three and then we have a
decimal and then we have a one and A
five one and A five now there's really
well there's one common way of doing
this but we'll talk about the different
ways you could express this as a word
but we know how to write this stuff to
the left this is pretty straightforward
this is just 63 so let me write that
down
so this is 60 63 63 and instead of the
decimal will write and and now there's
two ways to go here we could say and one
tenth and five we could say and one
tenth and five hundredths or we could
just say look this is 15 hundredths one
tenth is ten hundredths so one tenth and
five hundredths is 15 hundredths so
maybe I could write it like this
sixty-three and 15 15 hundredths
hundreds hundreds just like that now a
it might have been a little bit more
natural say how come I don't say one
tenth and then five hundredths and you
could but that would just make it a
little bit harder for someone's brain to
process it when you say it so you could
have it could have been 63 so let me
copy and paste that copy and paste it
could be 63 and and then you would write
and then you would write 1/10 1/10
for this digit right there and and five
hundredths and five hundredths five
hundredths 500 s and I think you can
appreciate that this is a little bit you
know sixty three and one tenth and five
hundredths is a hard is hard for most
people's brains to process but if say
1500s people get what you're saying
this right here let me not to beat a
dead horse but this right here this is
one tenth right here and then this is
five hundredths this is five hundredths
five over 100 but if you were to add
these two if you were to add one tenth
plus 500 so let's do that if you were to
add one tenth plus five hundredths plus
five hundredths how would you do it well
you need a common denominator 100 is
divisible by both 10 and 100 so multiply
both the numerator and denominator of
this character by 10 you get 10 on the
top and 100 on the bottom 1/10 is the
same thing as 10 over 100 10 hundredths
plus 5 hundredths is equal to 15 over
100 so this piece right here is equal to
15 over a hundred and that's why we say
63 and 15 hundredths